Générique
- Kathia Gilder: Bonjour à tous!
Ravie de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle édition de "Parlement
hebdo".
Les temps forts à l'Assemblée et
au Sénat revus et commentés par
notre invitée.
- Alexandre Poussart: On accueille
aujourd'hui Sophie Primas.
Vous êtes sénatrice LR des
Yvelines et présidente de la
commission des affaires
économiques du Sénat.
- Kathia Gilder: Il y a beaucoup
d'actualité pour vous.
Elisabeth Borne a lancé le
chantier des retraites.
La réforme prévoit notamment de
reculer l'âge légal de départ à 64
ans en 2030 et d'allonger la durée
de cotisation.
La bataille au Parlement et dans
la rue est annoncée.
Les députés ont donné leur feu
vert au projet de loi LR.
Ca porte sur le développement des
énergies renouvelables.
Il a été adopté avec le soutien
des socialistes.
Au Sénat, il y a le projet de loi
sur le nucléaire à l'ordre du
jour.
Il prévoit d'accélérer la
construction de réacteurs.
- Alexandre Poussart: La réforme
des retraites a été présentée
cette semaine par la Première
ministre.
La réforme prévoit le report de
l'âge légal de départ à 64 ans,
mais aussi des mesures sociales
comme la retraite minimum à
hauteur de 85% du SMIC net.
Cette réforme plaît aux
parlementaires de droite.
A gauche, les manifestations
s'organisent.
- C'est la mesure la plus
polémique de la réforme des
retraites.
L'exécutif a opté pour un report
progressif de l'âge légal de
départ à 64 ans.
- A compter du 1er septembre,
l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite sera relevé de trois mois
par an pour atteindre 64 ans en
2030.
- Le gouvernement a décidé de
jouer sur d'autres paramètres,
comme la durée de cotisation qu'il
entend allonger à 43 annuités
d'ici 2027.
L'exécutif vend une réforme
permettant de garantir l'équilibre
financier du système, qui se veut
aussi plus juste pour les
Français.
Meilleure prise en compte des
carrières longues ou hachées,
pénibilité du travail prise en
compte, le gouvernement veut
revaloriser les pensions minimums
à hauteur de 85% du SMIC.
Les syndicats font déjà front
commun pour bloquer une réforme
jugée injuste et brutale.
Laurent Berger s'y oppose
frontalement.
- Pour moi, c'est toujours non.
C'est toujours non pour l'ensemble
des organisations syndicales de ce
pays.
Pourquoi?
Cette réforme que l'on qualifie de
réforme des retraites, c'est
davantage une réforme des finances
publiques.
C'est une réforme d'équilibre
financier sur le dos des
travailleurs.
- Le gouvernement multiplie les
appels du pied à la droite.
Les LR seront incontournables pour
faire adopter la réforme.
Réforme qu'ils appellent de leurs
voeux depuis des années.
- Elisabeth borne propose sa
propre majorité pour voter la
réforme que nous avons rédigée.
- A gauche, la NUPES s'aligne sur
les syndicats et rejette la
réforme.
- L'accélération de cotisation,
c'est pour tout le monde.
C'est une mesure...
C'est un impôt sur les pauvres.
C'est un impôt sur la vie des
gens.
Il y a des gens qui ont des vies
difficiles.
- La bataille pour les retraites
est lancée et la mobilisation dans
la rue s'organise.
Premier grand test le 19 janvier.
Les huit principaux syndicats
appellent à une journée de grève
dans tout le pays.
- Alexandre Poussart: Cette
réforme des retraites présentée
par le gouvernement est une
réforme de la droite?
Une victoire pour vous?
- Sophie Primas: C'est une
victoire pour les retraites.
C'est une victoire pour le système
de répartition tel qu'il existe en
France depuis très longtemps et
qui garantit à l'ensemble des
salariés une retraite qui soit la
plus digne possible et la plus
préservée possible.
Ce qui est fait, c'est que la
droite réclame ça depuis plusieurs
années.
On avait commencé à le faire en
2010, au moment de la réforme.
Nous sommes responsables par
rapport à ce système de retraite.
La responsabilité est là.
Elle n'est pas dans des raccourcis
qui sont populistes et non
responsables.
Cette réforme est indispensable.
Comme l'a dit Bruno Retailleau
dans votre sujet, c'est une
réforme que nous voulons au Sénat
depuis plusieurs années sur les
grands principes.
Nous sommes plutôt satisfaits de
voir que le gouvernement s'est
rangé, après plusieurs épisodes.
On arrive à une réforme des
retraites, enfin.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous avez obtenu
beaucoup de choses.
Malgré tout, vous avez des lignes
rouges qui persistent sur cette
réforme?
- Sophie Primas: On est d'accord
globalement, comme Eric Ciotti ou
Bruno Retailleau qui ont discuté à
Matignon, mais nous avons des
avancées sociales qui sont à
obtenir.
Il faut revaloriser les petites
retraites.
Il faut que ces dispositions ne
s'appliquent pas aux nouveaux
retraités, mais à l'ensemble des
retraités qui sont concernés.
- Kathia Gilder: C'est une ligne
rouge pour vous?
- Sophie Primas: Ca sera dans les
lignes rouges de la droite.
C'est un souhait que nous avons.
Ensuite, nous avons des
dispositions que nous allons
améliorer.
J'ai eu une discussion récemment
avec le rapporteur au Sénat de
cette loi.
Nous avons des pentes de montée en
puissance que nous allons
peut-être renégocier.
Il y a des éléments qui sont de
nature, dans le dialogue avec les
syndicats, à apporter des
améliorations sociales.
Nous avons une disposition au
Sénat qui est une avancée sociale
très importante, notamment pour le
monde du handicap, qui est la
possibilité quand vous avez un
enfant handicapé de faire une
réversion de la retraite des
parents vers les enfants
handicapés.
C'est un sujet très important.
Nous tenons beaucoup à cette
réforme sociale.
- Alexandre Poussart: Quand vous
dites qu'il faut modifier et
améliorer les pentes de montée en
puissance, ça veut dire quoi?
- Sophie Primas: Il faut aller
plus doucement dans la pente des
trois mois supplémentaires par
année.
Il y a matière à négociation avec
le gouvernement pour améliorer et
adoucir cette pente.
- Alexandre Poussart: On pourrait
arriver à 64 ans plus tard?
- Sophie Primas: Un peu plus tard,
peut-être.
Ce sera dans les objets de
négociations entre la première
discussion qui aura peut-être lieu
à l'Assemblée nationale.
On ne comprend pas bien comment
cela va se discuter à l'Assemblée.
Il y a des groupes politiques qui
ont annoncé des amendements
considérables pour bloquer la
discussion.
- Kathia Gilder: La réforme telle
qu'elle a été présentée dans ses
grandes lignes semblerait faire
certains perdants, notamment ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt
et qui devraient cotiser pendant
44 ans.
- Sophie Primas: Non, nous voulons
travailler là-dessus avec le
gouvernement.
Il faut privilégier les
dispositifs de carrières longues.
Ce sont des ajustements.
Ce sont des cas particuliers
d'ajustement.
Il y a un principe général sur
lequel nous sommes d'accord, et
ensuite, il y a des cas
particuliers.
Nous proposerons des solutions.
- Alexandre Poussart: La
mobilisation sociale contre cette
réforme est lancée avec les
syndicats, et les partis de
gauche.
Jeudi prochain s'annonce comme un
jeudi noir dans la rue.
Vous craignez que la France soit
bloquée?
- Sophie Primas: C'est une crainte
que nous partageons tous.
C'est le blocage de la rue, que
nous craignons.
Nous sortons de trois années
horribles entre le Covid, la crise
sanitaire et la crise sociale...
Il y a aussi de l'anxiété à cause
du contexte international.
Nous redoutons un blocage du pays.
Ce ne serait pas responsable, pour
quelque travailleur que ce soit.
J'entends les récriminations des
salariés modestes et des cadres,
mais le pays est dans une
situation difficile et sensible au
niveau économique et énergétique.
Il faut être responsable.
J'ai presque de la peine de voir
Laurent Berger dans des postures
syndicales dures alors que
d'habitude, nous sommes dans un
dialogue avec lui.
- Kathia Gilder: Si l'opposition
persiste, vous accepterez des
concessions?
- Sophie Primas: Je pense que la
discussion au Sénat et les
avancées sociales que nous
pourrions obtenir sont des
éléments pour lesquels nous
trouverons des solutions.
Il faut que tout le monde soit
responsable.
- Kathia Gilder: On aura le temps
de parler de cette bataille qui
est annoncée début février.
Les députés ont adopté le projet
de loi qui accélère le
développement des énergies
renouvelables.
Le gouvernement a pu compter sur
les voix de la gauche pour faire
passer son texte.
Il y avait un petit bug
informatique à la fin de la
séance.
- A l'Assemblée, l'année commence
dans un éclat de rire.
- J'ai un problème en face.
Il y en a un problème à gauche.
- Le système électronique de vote
ne fonctionne plus.
3 fois de suite.
Il faudra sortir les bons vieux
bulletins en papier pour voter.
L'Assemblée dit oui à
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables.
Un premier succès pour le
gouvernement, soutenu par des
centristes.
Les socialistes, dans
l'opposition, ont aussi soutenu
cette loi.
- Il n'y a pas de pire opposition
qui soit dans une opposition
permanente.
Si le ciel est bleu, il faut le
dire.
S'il est gris et qu'il y a des
nuages noirs, il faut le dire
aussi.
- Pour les verts, le ciel est trop
gris.
La ministre a tenté encore une
fois de les convaincre de voter.
- Vous avez encore la possibilité
d'être dans la catégorie des
votants.
- Les écologistes s'abstiennent.
Ils disent qu'il n'y a pas que le
titre de la loi qui compte.
- C'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe.
Il faut que l'on accélère
réellement, et là, le texte
n'accélère pas.
- La France Insoumise et les
communistes ont voté contre, tout
comme Les Républicains et le
Rassemblement National, vent
debout contre le développement des
éoliennes.
- Nous sommes de ceux qui disent
non, qui refusent de massacrer nos
campagnes et le patrimoine,
refusent de détruire notre modèle
électrique performant, de ceux qui
ne sacrifient pas les paysages
pour un délire idéologique.
- Le Sénat a adopté ce projet de
loi en fin d'année dans une
version différente.
Les députés et sénateurs vont
trouver un accord.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous serez dans
cette commission mixte paritaire
pour essayer de trouver un texte
de compromis.
Il faudra satisfaire tout le monde
et réguler notamment les
socialistes qui ont donné leur
voix au texte.
Ce n'est pas un peu mission
impossible?
- Sophie Primas: Je ne pense pas.
Je veux dire au préalable que le
Sénat a largement voté.
D'abord, il y a quelque chose qui
m'agace dans ce texte.
Le Rassemblement National et des
positions extérieures se trompent
sur ce texte.
Toutes les énergies renouvelables
sont dans ce texte.
On met l'accent sur la biomasse,
sur le bio gaz...
Ca fait partie de l'essentiel du
texte.
La difficulté repose sur le fait
que ce n'est pas un texte sur les
éoliennes, seulement.
On a une posture qui est de donner
la main aux élus locaux.
Tout ce que vous entendez sur les
éoliennes, tout cela, c'est à la
main des élus locaux.
Les maires, mais aussi d'autres
élus.
C'est une réflexion territoriale
qui doit remonter en termes de
planification pour déterminer des
zones qui sont prioritaires pour
l'installation des énergies
renouvelables.
Il y a des possibilités pour les
maires de dire qu'ils veulent ça
ou pas ça.
On fait confiance aux territoires
pour être responsables sur le fait
qu'il faut des énergies
renouvelables en complément du
nucléaire pour satisfaire les
besoins en électricité de notre
pays.
On fait confiance aux maires.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le texte
issu de l'Assemblée nationale
donne toujours la main aux maires
pour définir les zones
prioritaires pour les énergies
renouvelables.
Il devrait y avoir un accord entre
sénateurs et députés?
- Sophie Primas: Il y a quelques
points à améliorer.
Sur les zones qui ne sont pas
prioritaires, on peut faire des
énergies renouvelables.
Il faut que le maire garde la
possibilité de dire oui ou non.
Il y a encore un accompagnement,
des informations à bien cadrer et
détailler.
J'ai confiance.
Je pense que l'on peut trouver un
accord.
- Kathia Gilder: Agnès
Pannier-Runacher craint des
postures politiques de la droite
dans ce débat.
Elle a raison?
- Sophie Primas: Ce ne sera pas
des postures politiques.
Nous sommes coresponsables de ce
texte avec le président de la
commission sur le développement
durable.
Nous sommes sur une ligne où
l'intérêt de la France et
l'acceptabilité des énergies
renouvelables sont un point
politique important.
- Kathia Gilder: Un accord est en
vue?
- Sophie Primas: On va essayer.
Ils ont retiré quelques
informations.
La gauche a retiré quelques
dispositions sur l'électricité.
A partir du moment où les
territoires donnent leur accord
pour qu'il y ait des zones
d'accélération d'énergie
renouvelable, il faut qu'ils aient
des bénéfices.
Il y a quelques petits points à
revoir avec le gouvernement.
- Alexandre Poussart: La semaine
prochaine au Sénat, un autre texte
énergétique sera débattu dans
l'hémicycle.
Ce projet de loi accélère la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires.
Emmanuel Macron a promis la
construction de six nouveaux
réacteurs EPR 2 lors de la campagne
présidentielle.
Ce projet arrive six mois avant un
texte sur l'énergie.
Pour certains sénateurs, il faut
d'abord avoir ce débat politique
avant de prévoir l'accélération de
la construction.
- Pourquoi ce projet de loi a lieu
maintenant?
Vous avez raison, le nucléaire,
c'est du temps long.
Vous avez dit qu'il y a tout un
tas de questions qui seront dans
la PPE.
Vous êtes obligée de faire de la
politique.
C'est un texte technique.
- Ce texte est important, car en
fait, on a analysé la conduite du
projet de nouvelles centrales
nucléaires en faisant un
rétroplanning.
Les dossiers de permis de
construire doivent être adoptés
dès maintenant si on veut
effectivement livrer des réacteurs
nucléaires dans 15 ans.
Là aussi, ce sont des dossiers qui
prennent plusieurs années.
Ce projet de loi s'étale sur
plusieurs années.
La coulée du premier béton, si on
veut tenir cet objectif de coulée
du premier béton à cinq ans, ça
suppose que ce projet de loi soit
adopté avant la fin du premier
semestre.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le Sénat
devrait voter ce projet de loi?
- Sophie Primas: On va le voter
avec des modifications que l'on a
apportées en commission cette
semaine.
Je partage l'avis de Fabien Gay.
On ne cesse de répéter qu'on
légifère mal et dans le mauvais
sens.
Il faut donner une vision, un
chemin, et ensuite, il faut se
donner les moyens d'y arriver.
On est dans une précipitation qui
ressemble à une précipitation
politique.
Vous voyez la réponse d'Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
Elle veut couler le premier béton
avant la fin du quinquennat.
Nous sommes dans des annonces
politiques et pas dans une
stratégie politique.
C'est de la politique politicienne
est pas visionnaire pour notre
pays.
On est très en retard sur le
nucléaire.
Les tergiversations sur le
nucléaire ont été énormes.
On dit simplement qu'on n'a pas
encore mis fin au décret qui
arrête l'arrêt des 12 réacteurs
nucléaires.
On n'a pas mis fin aux 50% maximum
du nucléaire dans le mixte
français.
C'est contradictoire avec ce
texte.
On est obligés d'enlever ces
dispositions.
- Kathia Gilder: Il faut inscrire
la relance du nucléaire dans la
loi?
- Sophie Primas: Ce sera l'objet
de la programmation pluriannuelle
de l'énergie.
Elle est annoncée au mois de juin.
Ce sera plutôt à l'automne.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le débat
aura lieu en automne?
- Sophie Primas: Peut-être, mais
s'il a lieu au mois de juillet, je
serais déçue pour les Français et
le Parlement.
On a l'habitude de nous faire des
lois sur l'énergie en plein mois
de juillet.
Ce n'est pas respectueux du débat
parlementaire.
C'est un sujet qui est très
important.
On le voit dans la crise
énergétique.
Si on est dans cette situation,
c'est parce que la vision depuis
10 ans n'est pas la bonne et n'a
pas déterminé la bonne direction.
- Alexandre Poussart: Ce sera
important dans ce débat, la
semaine prochaine, de supprimer
cet objectif de 50% de nucléaire
en 2035?
- Sophie Primas: C'est presque une
coordination juridique.
On ne peut pas dire qu'on fait de
l'accélération technique et
mécanique des procédures pour
installer des centrales nucléaires
tout en disant qu'on ne veut pas
plus de 50% en 2035.
C'est contradictoire.
Il y a un hiatus juridique.
- Kathia Gilder: Un autre sujet a
été débattu cette semaine à
l'Assemblée, la question de
l'uniforme à l'école.
Le RN a déposé une proposition de
loi pour le rendre obligatoire.
C'était dans le cadre de sa
journée d'initiative parlementaire
réservée.
Le texte a été rejeté en séance
publique.
- Qu'est-ce que nous souhaitons
pour les élèves?
Avec la tenue portée avec un
uniforme, il n'y a pas de
discrimination, pour les élèves.
- Kathia Gilder: La proposition de
loi a été rejetée, mais Brigitte
Macron dit oui à l'uniforme.
La droite aussi.
La majorité présidentielle
travaille même sur une proposition
de loi.
C'est la priorité?
- Sophie Primas: Evidemment non.
Le problème de l'école est
beaucoup plus profond et
compliqué.
D'ailleurs, la commission de
l'éducation au Sénat est en train
d'entamer un travail pour proposer
des choses sur l'école.
Après, je voudrais dire que je
déteste le mot d'uniforme.
C'est extrêmement conservateur.
Ca fait appel à des notions qui
n'ont rien à faire avec l'école.
Nous ne sommes pas à l'armée.
Nous ne sommes pas en 1912.
Ce terme d'uniforme est très mal
choisi.
Je pense qu'il faut parler de
tenue vestimentaire.
J'étais comme vous, un peu
dubitative.
On est arrivés dans une situation
où il faut aider les proviseurs de
lycées et les principaux de
collèges.
Ils ne savent plus quoi faire avec
les signes religieux, les
vêtements trop courts ou trop
bas...
Je trouve que c'est collaboratif,
ce genre d'initiative.
Il peut y avoir un groupe fait
avec des parents et des élèves qui
décident de quoi est composée la
tenue.
J'aime bien l'idée d'appartenance,
aussi.
Ca permet de créer une
appartenance à une communauté
éducative.
- Alexandre Poussart: Ca peut
régler les problèmes d'atteinte à
la laïcité?
On le voit, avec le port de
vêtements religieux et
d'inspiration islamique?
- Sophie Primas: Ca peut être une
réponse à ça.
J'aime bien m'appuyer sur cette
histoire d'appartenance.
Dans une société qui est divisée
par plein de choses, se dire qu'on
appartient à une communauté
éducative, c'est intéressant comme
concept.
- Kathia Gilder: On termine cette
émission avec l'agenda.
- Alexandre Poussart: Mardi
prochain, ce sera le début du
débat en séance sur le projet de
loi qui accélère la construction
de nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires
au Sénat.
Les sénateurs vont examiner aussi
le projet de loi sur les Jeux
Olympiques de 2024 avec beaucoup
de questions sur la sécurité.
- Kathia Gilder: A l'Assemblée, un
texte visant à surveiller les
produits de consommation sera
examiné.
Il sera aussi question d'une aide
universelle pour les victimes de
violences conjugales.
On va vous poser une question, car
on parle cette proposition de loi.
A l'Assemblée, Adrien Quatennens a
fait son retour.
Le député a été condamné à quatre
mois de prison avec sursis pour
violences à l'encontre de son
épouse.
Est-ce que ce retour d'Adrien
Quatennens à l'Assemblée vous
dérange?
- Sophie Primas: Ce qui me
dérange, c'est le manque de
cohérence d'une parole publique et
politique.
Quand on sait les positions du
groupe LFI et de monsieur
Quatennens en séance sur ces
sujets, des positions fermes et
fortes, voire agressives, voir son
propre comportement, ça pose la
question de la cohérence.
Son retour est choquant, mais
c'est une question de cohérence
personnelle.
Je me dis qu'au moins, il aurait
pu démissionner, même s'il peut se
représenter devant ses électeurs.
C'est à ses électeurs de décider
s'il peut retourner à l'Assemblée
ou pas.
C'est une question de conscience
personnelle et de cohérence
politique.
- Alexandre Poussart: Les députés
de la majorité ont dit qu'ils
déposeraient une proposition de
loi pour prévoir une peine
d'inéligibilité en cas de tels
délits.
- Sophie Primas: Je ne suis pas
pour ce genre de processus.
Je côtoie Aurore Bergé qui est
très brillante.
Sur le fond, pourquoi pas.
- Alexandre Poussart: Merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre
première invitée de l'année,
Sophie Primas.
Bonne année et merci à tous.
- Kathia Gilder: On se retrouve la
semaine prochaine. Bonne journée.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA